september also du was war das mir hey
was geht ab und herzlich willkommen bei
du warst in der falschen richtung noch
mal von vorne etwas gedacht und herzlich
willkommen bei einem neuen video ja ich
hoffe natürlich euch jedes guten ja auch
erstmal großen applaus
juli ist wieder da nach seinem gefühlt
drei wochen langen urlaub urlaub das war
arbeit auch mal wieder eingekehrt
ich finde ich echt nett jetzt habe ich
jemanden wieder der mir ein bisschen
hilft sondern mal klasse das heißt jetzt
wieder ein bisschen mehr mut in der
kamera so auf jeden fall habe ich
gesehen letzter part von diesem format
was ist gut jetzt letzter tag von diesem
format was ich gemacht habe alle sorten
von einer marke aus dem supermarkt erst
im letzten part milka-schokolade top
kommentar ich aber gesagt schreibt immer
eure wünschen die kommentare auch
kommentar für die nächste folge wakula
sorten und ich verrate eine stunde
unterwegs ich war es bei dem supermarkt
dann über dem wenn bei dem und dann
wieder hier weil ich habe im ersten fünf
sorten gefunden das war mir zu wenig und
jetzt nochmal 8 also ich hoffe das
reicht schon das ganze zeit 1
topstar ich noch nie gehört
so als erstes haben wir hier wake oder
die kenne ich noch von früher top star
wie gesagt habe ich noch nie gehört pep
sieht dann meine lieblingsmarke nein
dazu kommt natürlich die klassische coca
cola ist auch die einzige von allen die
ich trinke also dr pepper kommt aus
amerika ab die auch dann dr pepper afri
cola und sinalco also so viele
verschiedene kohlsorten auf einem haufen
interessant denn es im kopf
ihr wissen darüber wie häufig braucht
nicht mehr erklären ich nehme mir jetzt
aber ein glas saft und eis geführt weil
das sehr wichtig dass sich alle
kohlsorten eisgekühlt probiere um den
vollen geschmack zu erleben
nachdem wir unser tolles setup hier
aufgebaut haben würde ich sagen wir
fangen mit der ersten an und das ist
diese hier von der marke
nein ich finde es echt witzig nicht
betrieben wird es künftig also ohne spaß
habe ich noch nie in meinem leben zuvor
getrunken
wieso auch dazu 19 cent oder 29 cent
gekostet da kommt ein bisschen was uns
klar es ist ein ganz kleiner probier
schlucke irgendwie freue mich dass jetzt
alles zu trinken
man muss auch sagen die haben schon 21
uhr ich kann gleich bestimmt nicht
schlafen
okay leute froh dass heute noch mal die
ist ja eine größe doch ganz so gut
schmeckt wie dieses wasser eis was wenn
es geschmolzen ist und dann wenn man da
noch wasser ergänzt tut mir wirklich
leid und normalerweise scheint die marke
mal besser ab gehe ich da greifen sehen
oder besser geht nicht kommt ganz nach
rechts
okay das war schon einen griff ins klo
mama weiter mit topstar freue ich mich
auch mal hatte einen aldi das von aldi
das haben wir mal dass wahrscheinlich
die unternehmensinterne kolonne von der
marketingabteilung daniel kohler topstar
aber das ist teilweise mit absicht so
billig gemacht hast du es halt kaufst du
hast gute einfach haben wir doch mit der
schule aufgepasst haben wir in der uni
gelernt da ich merke schon die hat
wenigstens kohlensäure okay ich bin
gespannt auf euch
ich finde es vollkommen in ordnung war
er halt auch nicht so teuer
deswegen könnte man hier schon acht von
zehn punkten geben was musst du einmal
probieren absolut nach gut acht von zehn
vor allem leid augen muss sagen gefühlt
da alex und dabei acht von zehn stabil
man arbeite mit der freeway cola die
waffen wieder genau wo alle leute also
riechen tut die grausamen wir irgendwie
ein bisschen dass viel zu viel
kohlensäure drin wobei kalt ist die ein
jahr in ordnung die haut mich jetzt
nicht so um wie topstar freeway keine
ahnung würde ich dann einfach meine
sieben von zehn ging viktoria in der
kälte glaube ich wirklich weisse sonst
wenn du jetzt bis warm ist kannst du
ihnen tolle prof gut also dann einmal
die man hier hinter ich werde euch nicht
schaffen können das wird mir voll krass
wenn ich so ein glas cola getrunken ab
oder sind oder einfach vorhin auch
irgendwie mit dem essen war und da ne
cola getrunken haben bevor wir zur marke
pepsi kommen schreibt sehr gerne wieder
eure wünsche von welchen produkten nicht
mehr alle testen sollen in die
kommentare
aber die den kanal blogger aktivieren
jeden tag 19 uhr gibt's neues video also
ganz ganz wichtig schreibt sich hinter
die ohren also pepsi habe ich natürlich
schon mal betrunken allerdings auch
schon länger nicht mehr
ok korrigieren die hat einen ganz
anderen geschmack finde ich als diese
drei der geschmack ist jetzt nicht
schlecht kann man auf jeden fall machen
der ritter ist hier ja auch ein bisschen
teurer als bei diesem billigvariante
hier nenne ich jetzt einfach mal so oder
ein marken wie man auch immer möchte ich
würde aber sagen die partie steht hier
an richtiger stelle bekommt von mir auch
acht von zehn punkte
mehr ist leider nicht drin bin jetzt mal
gespannt ob ihr eine die zehn schafft
ich weiß natürlich die coca cola
schmeckt aber vielleicht überrascht mich
noch eine dieser kandidaten wir werden
sehen 3788 also top sound pepsi gleich
oder ja genau richtig gut erkannt alles
klar machen weiter mit
die sinalco schmeckt die sinalco
schmeckt diese nachgesagt werden ich
nehme das mit absicht immer ein bisschen
weniger weil sonst habe ich leichtes
spiel cola cola deutsche nummer fünf
sinalco bin ich mal gespannt
man muss natürlich sagen dann schmeckt
alles schon sehr ähnlich
also dazu ja zu differenzieren ich
konnte irgendwie schwer das ist genauso
ein geschmack irgendwie hier schon mal
hatte da sind selbst manchmal geschmacks
profi alex die hände gebunden
muss ich auch eine muss ich acht punkte
geben finde ich lecker kann man auf
jeden fall machen und dann kommst du mal
eben hier überhaupt passt sich auch
einfach mit zoom sogar komplett dieses
zu achten cola habe ich noch nie mein
ganzes leben probiert also wirklich
nicht hört sich auf jeden fall
ich glaube das ist so eine sonne hipster
variante von krone gibt es in allen
hipster reden kann das sein
also meine lieben auf euch
was mir direkt auffällt wir haben einen
ganz leichten hauch von kohlensäure was
sie gar nicht mal so schlecht finde es
super schwierig zu beschreiben aber nach
dem abgang der coder hat man so einen
leichten sonst ganz komisches gefühl
hier im gaumen also hier auch hier
anfangen so das ist so ein bisschen und
weiß sie das fühlt sich so es wird da
irgendwie was kleben bleiben so fühlt
sich das an
bei mir zumindest und das macht
irgendwie den geschmack von vorher
kaputt weiß was ich meine
weißt du wenn du kannst ja wenn du
getroffen hast dass es an den zähnen so
bisschen komisch ist
und das ist extrem hier und deswegen
gibt es von mir 15
sorry ok zweimal auf hot pepper also hey
was war lassen jetzt ist die kamera das
gefahr dass der boden nass geworden ja
das habe ich jetzt nun verstanden 0
punkte also wir hatten diesen tisch mal
gekauft und man jetzt ist dieses schöne
wird sich sehr schöne pulli im eimer
könnt ihr noch einen schicken
die richtigen die total komisch wir
müssen das ganze zu ende machen und dann
erst mal bisschen also dr pepper ich bin
vom direkt schlecht eingestimmt
muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen also was
soll das denn vor allem ich habe die
wirklich nicht geschüttelt oder so
eigentlich hätte ich alle vor diesem
video system hilft so kohler am 7
[Musik]
bald habe dich riechen die da kommt ja
da steckt ja der zucker die nase sowie
darum jetzt nicht um
aber ich finde auch nicht schlecht da
kann man eigentlich nur sagen sieben
punkte den geschmack kann ich jetzt gar
nicht genau erläutern
aber es ist halt es schmeckt extrem süß
schmeckt süßer als alle die ich vorher
probiert habe manche feiern das
vielleicht das ist halt so krass süß
schmeckt oder so intensiv süß ich eher
weniger
deswegen gibt es von mir sieben von zehn
und ich bin voll mit cora nevada mama
ein punktabzug gibt es noch 69 und
kommen wir zu guter letzt zu coca-cola
gewannen ri bekommt man manchmal direkt
mal ein bisschen mehr rein
also wie schon eben gesagt ich trinke
eigentlich nur coca cola
wenn ich mir selber cola kaufen und
nummer acht
das ist halt dann dieser cola geschmack
den man auch als cola geschmack
definiert weist man kann keine dr pepper
keine pepsi sowieso keinen ein cola
mithalten meiner meinung nach absolut
die beste cola
da kann man nur zehn von zehn geben
gewinner heute glückwunsch leute hier
seht ihr noch mal das ranking eigentlich
ganz interessant dass nur noch um den
kanal schreibt weitere ideen für weitere
parks in die kommentare
und auch super gerne mal welche von
diesen eure lieblings cola ist kann
schon fast gar nicht mehr reden weil ich
soviel kursen braucht habe das was von
mir wir sehen uns morgen heißt app
instagram ab haut rein